[Music]
welcome today you'll be hearing about
nests use of cloud platform to prototype
massive scale services and using a
philosophy I affectionately refer to as
launching and iterating so I'm San
McVitie I'm the tech lead of cloud
dataflow and I'm really thrilled to be
joined today by Kevin and Peter from
nest and most of the talk today is gonna
be their show because you know we just
built the infrastructure they did all
the hard work so I'll give most of the
time to them but before then by way of
an introduction I'll talk briefly about
what launching and iterating looks like
on Google's cloud and then they'll go
into a little bit more depth on what
specifically nest is doing and how
they're building their services so
launching and iterating one of the
things I really love about working at
Google is this idea that you can take an
idea and you can prototype it you can
see what works what doesn't
tweak it fail fast succeed quickly if
you're lucky but but you can do that and
you can quickly make progress that way
and you're gonna see how the nest folks
did that and what I love about the cloud
is it it brings this capability to
everyone it's not something that is that
is locked in at Google it is something
that anybody that uses Google cloud has
access to so you sort of take one thing
away from this presentation it's gonna
be I hope it's this quote one engineer
no systems background and three days and
this isn't isn't an outlier this is this
is how you can quickly use the cloud to
validate ideas to move forward make
progress succeed quickly for example we
had a hackathon recently on the dataflow
team and this is what it looked like
where in a matter of days people were
building things on infrastructure and
turning those ideas into a reality to
say hey this is something we want to run
with or
maybe not so good so in making these
things a reality let's talk briefly
about some of the tech that it's
available so first one is is Google
bigquery so this is your you know fast
economical data warehouse for
large-scale analytics and you can really
throw all your data in here you don't
have to worry about indices or sharding
you you just send all your data to
bigquery you can use sequel standard
sequel to ask questions about the data
and you don't have to know if those
questions look like upfront you're not
doing any sort of pre optimization so if
it turns out that you're asking the
wrong question so you didn't know what
questions you were gonna ask it's there
to iterate on and there's no
backtracking no BRE partitioning
necessary now to get the data there in
the first place you need something like
App Engine so this allows you to you
know build a scalable web application
quickly on any of any of the languages
that Google's infrastructure supports
you can stand up with service simply
throw up some endpoints and if we're
talking about devices that you just want
to send simple rest calls from like for
the nest folks you know this is a great
way for them to phone home send
telemetry data quickly and then you can
analyze that offline now if you want
something a little more full-featured
than sequel that's where something like
cloud dataflow comes in so using the
Apache beam model cloud dataflow
provides a way to write your code and
run it in batch or streaming mode so
upfront you don't know if you care about
latency you can iterate on your code
while it's in batch mode and then if
latency turns out to be something you
care about you can run it in a stream
processing fashion also you don't have
to worry about provisioning it's a
managed service it has auto scaling so
you're not worrying about replicas up
front you just say hey here's my code I
want to run it I want to see how how it
works and then sort of stepping back a
level in general you don't even have to
know which cloud you want to run on
first you want a prototype on Google's
cloud our commitment to open source
means that if it turns out the
investment isn't the right place you can
move because you're not locked in so
with bigquery for example you have
standard sequel support or you can run
those queries elsewhere for App Engine
you can take your container and run it
on kubernetes and for data flow you have
this engine portability via beam where
you can run that on the data flow runner
you can run that on SPARC anything that
implements this standard so altogether
this provides this ability to launch and
iterate you don't have to answer all
these questions provisioning all these
things upfront you just have to have an
idea and you can validate that idea
quickly without letting all these
details get in the way so thank you
again for coming and let me introduce
Kevin from nest thanks Sam so I want to
start here just by introducing nest and
a little bit about what our mission is
and what we're trying to accomplish and
how we're gonna use the GCP
infrastructure that Sam's team has
worked on so at nest our mission is to
create a home that takes care of the
people inside it and the world around it
and we accomplish this mission via the
different products that we have so we
take unloved products in homes and try
to reinvent them and make them smarter
make them do more for you so we started
with the Learning Thermostat follow that
up with a smoke and CO alarm and then an
indoor and outdoor camera but more than
just the products we have the app that's
behind it that lets you actually
interface with the device your devices
and your home and the nest service which
sort of backs everything up so nest is
sort of often considered a hardware
company but are truly much more than
that because the apps and the services
that are behind everything are really
the important bits so I'm part of the
algorithms team at Nesta I want to
introduce a little bit what my team is
responsible for so we are the team that
sort of takes the the data from takes
our data and tries to make intelligent
features for your devices and so we have
a principle in us that any data that's
measured by our device should return
value to you the user of it and we do
this via features like home away assist
in autoschedule we're trying to make
sure that when you're not
when you don't want your home to be
heating or cooling itself we can turn
off your AC or your heating and make
sure that you save energy
we also use our sensors to build thermal
models of the home and this lets us
offer features like time to temp so that
when you change the temperature of your
home we tell you how long it's going to
take to get there so you know maybe
you're leaving in an hour you don't need
to turn it to a temperature that it's
not gonna reach for two hours Russia
rewards is a partnership with energy
services and energy programs this lets
us actually pre-cool your home before
maybe a time of day when it's going to
be Energy's gonna be very expensive and
this will let you save money plus let
the energy companies avoid these really
high peak loads that can cause rolling
blackouts steam check and sun block are
both features that fuse multiple sensors
on the device to make the device smarter
and do more so with steam check we can
detect the difference between steam and
smoke and actually build a smoke alarm
that is less annoying not going to go
off at 7:00 in the morning when you get
out of the shower wake the kids up and
then with some luck we can detect is the
temperature in the home actually going
up or is it just the Sun has come
through the window now and is hitting
the thermostat and we we see a rise in
temperature but your home is still the
same temperature and we don't need to
waste energy cooling it so my team's
responsible for taking these features
all the way from the very beginning from
maybe an idea as a sheet of paper in
your lab notebook through through the
production scale and so what I want to
talk about today is how we use GCP to
really take these concepts from the
notebook and show that they're feasible
and worth investing in so sort of at
this very beginning stage we're still
trying to find out is this possible is
it something we can do and so we don't
want to invest a ton of the company's
resources on an idea that we haven't
even shown is doable yet and so the
first thing we need to do is build a
prototype and collect data and so at
this scale or at this stage we sort of
sitting at a lab bench maybe have a
sensor that we've ordered from the
manufacturer or trying to figure out you
know can we measure the things we need
to measure and we found that each
engineer had a very different method
that they like to run their experiments
that they like to store and organize
their data some people would use you
know Google spreadsheet to keep track of
all the experiments they were running
people would actually embed the
different parameters in the filename
itself so they could parse it out later
and this just didn't really scale we
weren't able to communicate very well
you know what each different engineer
was doing and it was hard to make that
data available to the people that needed
to see it to make their decisions early
on and so we were sort of faced with
this problem of how do we collect and
label data in a scalable way and so we
need to take data that's sitting on a
sensors probably plugged into a laptop
maybe a Raspberry Pi something like that
and get it to the engineers that are we
gonna use it and because this is GCP
next you can probably guess how I'm
gonna go about this so we want to build
an app engine project to take that data
put it in a few data stores and then
feed it back to the engineers and so we
build a service an app engine that
allows ingest and data query we use
cloud storage which is google's object
store to store this blobs of sensor data
so this is temperature samples humidity
smoke things like that that are really
just you know CSV or JSON blobs and then
the important bit here is using cloud
datastore as a metadata service and so
here we can actually label their data in
a sort of scalable way a way that you
know everybody can understand and we can
query that to get the data back so we
can say give me all the experiments that
were run at room temperature give me all
the experiments that were run at 50
degrees C so we can make sure that as we
develop our products we know exactly how
they're working and the first thing we
found in building the service is that
people wanted to use it and so now we
have the same data being used by the
hardware engineers to validate their
sensors we have the same data being used
by our embedded team as they're sort of
trying to prototype and take these
algorithms and put them on the devices
and what's more is this data was
immediately available to them so as soon
as people collect the data in the lab
now they can immediately query it
sitting at their desk running on
simulations things like that and then we
can scale that up even further and plug
this directly into our development
infrastructure and our build system so
now as we start implementing the
algorithms on the device we can pull
that data down into the build system
every time we have a new build and make
sure the algorithm is still doing what
we expect it to be doing and this is
really powerful us because now we can do
regression testing we can make sure that
as we develop new features we don't go
backwards on any of our other features
and finally we can take that output from
our build system it actually feed it
back into the metadata so now we have
tags on all of our data showing which
builds were successful which builds
weren't we can start exporting this data
into bigquery and really doing analytics
on it so we can find out you know is
there is there a trend is there a
pattern is there maybe a particular
algorithm that has trouble at very high
temperatures or very low temperatures if
there's a particular data set that you
know had a bunch of events all happening
at once we can see that and say oh maybe
we have a timing problem on the the
prototype that we're working on that we
need to dig into and make sure that our
software is addressing that and this
sort of all can can work because we have
a common data set that's shared by
everybody and we know what we're we're
trying to experiment on and so this lets
us build better algorithms because we
have better data and more importantly we
get to spend more time on collecting the
data and less on all of the
record-keeping because the service
handles the record-keeping for us and as
Sam mentioned earlier this whole service
took one engineer that didn't have any
services experience at all the
algorithms team is mathematicians
roboticist machine learning experts it
doesn't cover any systems or services
engineers and it was able to be built
over a three-day period which is really
powerful so now we're at the point where
we sort of proven the hardware we
understand that our sensors can collect
the right information and we can sort of
implement the algorithm but auger looms
don't exist in a vacuum
they're actually very important that we
interact with the user during our
algorithms and so we want to understand
how a user is going to use the different
features on the device and how they're
going to be affected by it and so we
need another service for this to
actually explore these different
features and so we have our our nest
cloud which I've sort of shown here that
sort of interfaces between your phone or
the your laptop and all the different
smart devices that you might have but at
this sort of phase of the product
development we're still very small we're
still sort of trying to figure out
how this feature really works and so
what we actually want is a small service
something that we can iterate on really
quickly we can deploy maybe once every
10 minutes at deploy every hour things
like that and we're just not ready to
integrate it with our production app and
our production service and go through
all of the release processes that are
needed there and we want to make our
algorithms engineers directly
responsible for the logic and
implementation so that if they find
something that's not working they can
immediately address it and fix it and so
again we can build a simple real-time
service and GCP to do this so we'll
start with App Engine as our REST API
that lets both the devices and the apps
communicate together we'll feed that
through some algorithm logic to
implement whatever feature we're looking
to implement and then store the state of
the device in the claim cloud data store
this lets us use cloud datastore is sort
of the backing store that either an app
or a device can query to figure out
what's going on so you might imagine
storing temperature data there or
something like that and again we can
export this to bigquery to let us do
analytics on how a user is interacting
with the device so we can store a record
of you know did the temperature get
changed by the app or by the device and
how which direction is things flowing do
people prefer to use the device to
change the temperature or do they prefer
to use the app to change the temperature
and we're fortunate at us to have a very
active internal test group so we can
actually get quite a good set of data
from just all of our internal employees
trying things out for us so I want to
walk through just a little bit of how
simple this actually is to build by
showing a bit of code here so the first
thing we wanted was real-time state
communications so we want the apps and
the devices to communicate together and
this will do with App Engine and
specifically in Python here with using
the web app - web framework and so we
just need two functions here a get
function at a post function so that we
can update the state and we can fetch it
back and then we use cloud datastore to
actually store the date the data sort of
do all the heavy lifting for us and the
API is that Google Cloud provides are
really simple here you can see in the
get function we just create a queue
using the device ID and fetch the data
and write it
- ever called that function and then for
sort of similarly in Reverse we write
the data directly into cloud datastore
cloud datastore no sequel so we can add
or remove fields as we need and it's
very easy to update this and it really
is just these ten lines of code that let
us do this and so the next step we want
is using bigquery for analytics so this
lets us sort of track how things change
over time and the bigquery streaming API
lets us really quickly send data over to
bigquery and make it immediately
available so now we can very quickly
sort of look at things in real time and
don't have to wait to do our analytics
you know the day after we can iterate
much faster as Sam was talking about and
again because all of this is sort of an
integrated part of GCP it's very quick
getting credentials for authentication
is just a couple of lines at the top
that means that we don't have to worry
about implementing our own
authentication mechanism anything like
that and we can be guaranteed that it's
a secure system we can know that only
this App Engine application is allowed
to talk to this bigquery table to send
data over to it and not not worry about
configuring it ourselves and then again
at the bottom it's just a very simple
API call using the libraries bigquery
provides to send data over to do that
service and then finally we can use this
service to explore higher-level logic so
instead of just persisting and logging
state we can actually implement this
complex logic and so here I've sort of
put a function in the middle that I've
labeled apply logic which sort of sounds
like cheating but it really isn't
because all it is is a Python function
and that's that's the magic is that we
don't have to do a whole lot of extra
work we just write a Python function
that takes an existing state and new
state and does some arithmetic or does
some logic and figures out what we want
to do and this lets us iterate again
very very quickly so that if something
we want to try something out we don't
have to go through the process of
creating a build for the device
validating that that builds not going to
brick the device and then doing a
rolling software update on our test
devices we can actually just very
quickly change something in the service
redeploy see how it's going
and keep doing that over and over until
we have something that works well there
are a bunch of other useful things that
are just sort of hidden away in App
Engine that make developing pretty easy
are pretty remarkable and one of these
is the default deferred library that
I've highlighted here so this lets you
schedule things to happen later by
taking advantage of the App Engine task
queue and so here I'm deferring the
bigquery insert because that can
sometimes be a an operation that maybe
takes a little bit of time and so we
don't want to put that in the real-time
loop of devices fetching state and so we
just do that sort of a synchronously and
then additionally I've written this to
schedule a callback so in 300 seconds
that a callback function will execute
and maybe we can make a different
decision that we made upfront or
reconsider the decision we made
initially and that again is a very
powerful thing to be able to do and it's
even more powerful that we can do it
with a single line of code and all of
this sort of has the function of making
services easy for us so everything just
sort of scales datastore bigquery App
Engine are all things that just scaled
by default and so we don't have to worry
when you know our little tin devices
that we were testing on all of a sudden
becomes the whole company trying out our
product you never want to be in that
situation where you have to tell someone
oh I just built this on my desktop and I
can't yeah I can't let anybody else use
it now we can make sure that everything
that we're building anybody in the
company that needs to use it can use it
you know if it spent any time managing
VMs again not a services engineer not a
systems engineer I don't want to make
sure that I've closed all the right
ports on some machines somewhere because
App Engine is the interface it's sort of
secure by default and the built-in
authentication lets us use all of the
Google services and make sure that those
services are secure and that the only
data that can be the data can only be
accessed by us and really we get to
focus on the logic of the applications
which are the bits we're good at and let
Google focus on the mechanics which is
the bits they're very good at and then
from there I'm going to turn it over to
Peter who's going to tell you about how
we scale all this out and monitor it in
production
so hi my name is Peter Garbowsky I'm the
tech lead and manager of the data
integration team at nest I wanted to
start off by saying thank you to Sam for
giving us a great overview of the manage
technologies available within Google and
I thank you to Kevin for a great
walkthrough of how they his team
develops in prototypes algorithms at
nest so I'd like to talk to you today a
little bit about how we think about
scaling out those algorithms the systems
that make them scale and also once they
have been deployed how we modern monitor
them and make sure they do what we think
that they're doing so this is I this is
our architecture to get started I'd like
to give a quick tour through our
architecture this won't be the focal
point of the tark but it will come in
handy and provide some useful context
for later in our discussion one of the
things I wanted to highlight right away
is that a Sam mentioned we've got both
open source and managed technologies
here and being able to co-locate those
gracefully within the same environment
was a major draw for using GCP so you
can see some managed technologies that
Sam talked about you've got data flow
and bigquery
you'd also see some open source
technologies that we use like apache
storm apache Kafka and Hadoop HDFS
so our system begins with like many
others with the data locking service
we've got many devices out in the field
we've got cameras we've got smoke
detectors we've got thermostats they're
all sending data up to the service
they're sending it up in different
formats they're sending it up in
different sizes they're sending it up in
different shapes no matter what size or
shape they're sending it up in its
received by the data logging service
this sits out in front of our
architecture and it's responsible for
three things so it's designed to be very
purposely straightforward it receives
the data it authenticates that the data
act came from an S device that is not
someone trying to spoof us and it then
it writes it to a durable store from
there we move to the processing layer
the processing layer is made up of storm
and Kafka on the storm side of things
we've got one topology that is
responsible for each kind of data that
we process at nest but no matter what
which topology it is no matter which
data source it is that topologies do the
same thing they extract the data from
whatever format it's in
they transform it into Avro and then
they load that data into Kafka from
there we move to the loading layer the
loading lady consists of cloud data file
and I want to highlight one of the
really nice features of cloud dataflow
which is as Sam mentioned it can run in
both batch and streaming mode so this
might sound like a simple thing but in
edits up making our operational works
those a lot easier we can use streaming
mode for streaming data in real time for
the normal operation of the service but
we can also use batch mode by just
changing a few lines of configuration to
do historical back loads or particularly
in large load jobs so this simple
feature ends up saving us a ton of time
from their date of thoe writes into our
storage layer we primarily use bigquery
although as I mentioned before we also
maintain a footprint in BigTable and
HDFS
and so up into this point what we've
seen so far it constitutes our data
platform everything else that we're
going to talk about now constitutes the
applications or applications that run on
top of the platform we've got a number
of different applications we've got some
monitoring applications and reporting
applications that help us make sure our
devices are doing what we think they
should be doing and also that our
general fleet health is is strong
we've got machine learning algorithms
that come from Kevin and his team that
we've scaled up to run on production
we've also got a number of analytics
applications or various workflows from
our consumer analytics teams and finally
a number of consumer insights that we
take and transform the data from the
devices back into value for our
customers I'll talk about to my favorite
consumer insights at the patient's later
on in the presentation so at this point
we're at a point that I'm sure many of
you have been up before we've got all
the data loaded we've got all the data
stored now what do we do with it so we
we had the same question we went out and
talked to all of our device teams the
camera team the smoke detector team the
thermostat team all of the algorithms
teams to see what they might like to do
with it all of the analytics teams to
see how they might like to use it and no
matter the team that we talked to the
results came back the same they wanted
to be able to do fleet level analysis
quickly and easily so to help them out
we built our first prototype we built it
using PI spark and Zeppelin two great
open source technologies out of Apache
it looks something like this
I would like to take a minute to walk
through it so this was HVAC runtime is
calculated with Pi spark for those of
you who aren't familiar HVAC stands for
heating ventilation and air conditioning
so it's a measure of how much time your
furnace or how much time your air
conditioner was running throughout the
course of a day you can see on the
x-axis here we've got a fraction of day
with HVAC running this is a histogram on
the y-axis you've got the fraction of
the device population so all the way on
the right you see that about 5% of the
population was running a hundred percent
of the day all the way on the left you
see about 20 percent of the population
was running not at all during the course
of the day this might be alarming
except for that this data came from a
set of test devices so that leads into
one of the major complexities that we
found with this system it was really
costly to run analyses like this on all
of production we had the capacity to run
it on production and for the most
important works those we did but if you
wanted to think about other types of
work those it became really tricky to do
so one of the main reasons this was so
tricky is that our storage was coupled
to our compute so a less we picked
exactly the right instance type with
exactly the right amount of RAM exactly
the right amount of storage and exactly
the right number of CPUs we always had
too much of one and not enough of the
other I was describing this problem to
my roommate as I was preparing this talk
and she mentioned that she had the same
problem except for she had it when she
went to the store and she bought chips
and she bought salsa so no matter what
she always said too much one and not
enough for the other we've got the same
problem at nest
except for we've got it with storage and
compute of course that leads to frequent
resource contention we had one cluster
where the data were located we are in
both high priority workflows on it but
also lower priority analytics tasks
which meant that the lower priority
analytics tasks were frequently
preempted or bumped from the work though
this meant that our analytics team had
to either go back and reschedule or
rerun those workflows or have gaps in
their analysis that also meant that our
team took on the role of a part-time
sysadmin we got excuse me we got many
phone calls saying hey this works those
just been
it turn out the memory can you help us
get it running again which wasn't a
great working environment for the team
there are a number of operational
complexities that we ran into as well so
PI spark and Zeppelin were great tools
but they weren't built to do this sort
of dashboarding so we ended up building
a separate service that was responsible
for generating JSON blobs that
represented these templates that we
wanted to create loading them into the
notebook cache of the Zeppelin monitor
restarting the service so the Zeppelin
monitor picked up on the new notebooks
this worked well for one users but you
can imagine his multiple users started
trying to use the system and it was
frequently restarting all the time it
wasn't a great experience for them
additionally there was a constraint that
there was a maximum number of notebooks
that could be loaded on the machine at
once so we had to vote a second service
that was responsible for backing these
notebooks up to durable store and then
pulling them back in when we needed them
it wasn't a great experience for the
people who wanted to see the data this
next point is an especially important
one I want to take a moment to talk
about it
one of the things that we care most
about nest is protecting our users data
and protecting our users privacy and
many of the mechanisms that from the
systems that we were using provided only
clunky authentication and authorization
which made it difficult to do the fast
and flexible data analysis to return
value to our customers similar problem
was that it became very difficult to
build analyses back to different teams
so for example imagine that the
thermostat team came to us and said hey
we've got this great new data type that
we want to store we know that your
cluster is full we know that we're gonna
have to expand the cluster what's it
gonna take to load that data type in it
was difficult to figure out exactly how
much that extra space would cost
we had some heuristics to help us come
up with estimates they always proved to
either be too high or too low and so the
end we ended up building most of the
cost back to our team which was great
from a billing perspective or a
management perspective but terrible from
a team bottom line perspective and
finally if you were an analytics team
that had already generated some data
that you wanted to use to augment or
color your analysis it was difficult to
get data into the system you had to
learn a new set of tools you had to get
the appropriate
permissions and then you had to figure
out how to join and link those two
together so I'd like to take a little
bit of time to talk about the solution
that we came up with so on the left here
this is a zoomed in view of the
architecture that we discussed
previously and it starts with the events
in cloud bigquery up at the top so those
events are the same events that were
loaded from Kafka into bigquery by
dataflow once we've got the data
available in bigquery we then built a
processing library on top of it the
processing library was responsible for
two different pieces one there's a
number of nest specific nuances in our
data set so the processing law library
was aware of those nuances and provided
a higher level abstraction on top of
them to make it easier to work with and
to one of the most frequent kinds of
analyses that we do at nest is time
series analysis so it provided a number
of very useful higher level abstractions
for time series analysis one of the
really nice things as Sam mentioned was
that even though we're running in cloud
data file the code is just Apache beam
is completely open source completely
portable so if we wanted to we could
pull this cut code out of data flow and
run it elsewhere run it on our own flesh
to run it wherever we might want to
we're not planning on doing that we love
working with data flow but it is really
nice to have the flexibility to do that
wherever we do the computation after
it's complete we load the data back into
bigquery for further processing or
analysis and from there there's a number
of really nice integrations that make it
easy to visualize two of my favorites
are up on the screen you've got data
studio and data lab but it's also got
really easy connectors for Excel or
tableau or Google sheets or whatever you
might want to use to take a look at it
so I'd like to talk about two advantage
or a couple of advantages from using the
system first and foremost was also auto
scaling this auto scaling was huge for
us it made it really easy for us to
develop code locally to test code
locally and then to push it out to our
production cluster to run at scale by
only changing a few configs and to
demonstrate how powerful this was I'd
like to tell a short story we had a
camera systems engineer who was a great
engineer but again didn't have too much
familiarity with building services or
analytics workflows he was able to get
up and running using the libraries we
created in only a day so there was a
huge operational
advantage from using this system part of
the reason it was such a big win was
that storage or we were finally able to
decouple storage from compute so as I
mentioned before all of this storage was
handled by bigquery all of the compute
was handled by dataflow so we could add
new logs to the system without worrying
about scaling out data flow or we could
add new analysis pipelines without
worried about Skerritt scaling out
bigquery and finally because everything
runs as a managed service there was no
more resource contention with production
jobs which meant that the analytics
teams could run their jobs without
worrying about backfill but excuse me
without worrying about backfill and also
without worrying about having winners or
missing windows in their data sets and
that our team got many fewer late-night
phone calls there are a number of
operational advantages that well this
first one is a big one they've got this
really nicely defined access control
model that made it really easy for us to
grant people access to the right data at
the right time and only when they need
it so their access control model was
great and increased our operating
security a similar system we're finally
able to build analyses by team so
whenever you kick off a work flow you're
able to set a billing can shape or a
bidding ID that means that the teams
that kickoff works those are built for
only the computer cycles they use and
nothing more and finally as we mentioned
previously really great options for data
visualization data studio data lab to
blow anything that you want to work with
is available so I'd like to revisit one
of the example use cases that we talked
about before this is the same age factor
runtime analysis except for this time
it's computed with a cloud data file so
on the x-axis you see the day that it
ran on the y-axis you see the fraction
of time that your furnace or air
conditioner was on it starts out low in
October while things are still pretty
warm it increases through January 10th
where there was a huge storm in the
Northeast and then it falls back off as
things start to warm up in the spring
this is a really simple computation but
this graph hides a really important fact
this is one of the first times that we
were able to run an analysis like this
on all of production so all of those
sampling pieces that I talked before
where you're worried about getting the
wrong population or missing population
or masking populations we don't have to
worry about
this is great if you want to build more
complicated or more nuanced machine
learning models on top of the data you
can be sure that you're hitting all of
the points so with that I want to
highlight that even a simple computation
like the one that I just mentioned even
just figuring out HVAC on and off
periods can have some really positive
returns and value for our customers this
is one of my favorite products that we
offer at nest this is the monthly Energy
Report so every month we email our nests
teachers and say how much energy used
how much energy used as compared to last
month we try to sprinkle a little
machine-learning on top of it to say why
your energy use has changed maybe it got
colder maybe the weather changed maybe
you adjusted your thermostat to be more
comfortable in your home we also provide
one of my favorite statistics that nest
so every month we give a summary of how
much energy people have saved by
installing nests across the entire
population this is the one from January
so this is current through January 31st
since October 11 I'm sorry October 2011
nesters have saved eleven point three
billion kilowatt hours which is enough
energy to freeze all of the ice
necessary for 2 million ice skating
rinks so that's a pretty cool insight
that comes out of relatively
straightforward data analysis once
you're able to perform it on the entire
fleet it's also a lot of energy to save
simply by installing a thermostat fast
inflexible data analysis also lets us
help prove how efficient our devices are
so we're really proud to announce that
nest was the first thermostat in America
with an Energy Star certification and
some of the fast and flexible data
analysis techniques that I talked about
helped us be able to prove this
efficiency out so with that I'd like to
wrap up using the technologies available
to us within GCP
provided an easy pass from development
to production paved by shared and
scalable tooling throughout so that
means that an algorithms engineer like
Kevin can develop and prototype data
sets using one set of tools and then
take those same tools to do analysis
when he deploys the algorithm to
production there's no need to learn
another tool set for doing data at scale
or for doing smaller data allows
locally the access control models to
provide give the right people the right
access to the right data at the right
time and similarly the billing
operations that they allow for allows
you to build the right teams for what
they use and more importantly for only
what they use but most importantly the
data availability and access control is
provided by GCP help us further our
mission of creating the home that cares
so with that I'd like to thank you to
all of the team members at nest and
Google who contributed to these projects
these weren't built by a single person
we have a great engineering engineering
team that nests of them who are here
today that are wonderful to work with
we've got a great engineering team at
Google including people like Sam who
have helped us along the process so
thank you to both and I'd also like to
thank you in the audience roots staying
in listening will be outside after the
talk feel free come up ask any questions
that we might have say about Mike I
mentioned we've also got some energy
other data services engineers from nest
who can help to field questions or
provide more information so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you